over the weekend
Democrats bent over backwards now not to
lament the outrageous lack of
truthfulness by former FBI director
Andrew McCabe but to lament his firing
what the president did was one of the
biggest I think character flaws that we
see in him he just lacks human decency
it was cruel the way he did this to fire
someone literally hours before they
would have got their pension president
Trump announced we have 90 days to get
McCabe before he retires he put out
basically a hit on him and say do this
before he qualifies for retirement I've
never seen a president knighted States
go after an individual this is awfully
mean-spirited now frankly he should have
been sacked a long time ago and you
notice what the Democrats weren't
discussing there but let's face it the
government here followed a meticulous
process and they did this all by the
book which is good the Justice
Department's inspector general forwarded
its findings on the conduct of McCabe to
the FBI's office of Professional
Responsibility and it was they who
determined that McCabe should be fired
it's a big decision now just so you all
know this office is staffed with career
personnel not Trump loyalists so when
the government learns of wrongdoing
shouldn't it act immediately without
regard of who cares when someone's
retiring if it was wrong it was wrong
and that's what the Justice Department
did here well you'll notice that none of
the McCabe defenders that you just heard
mention the actual reasons for his
dismissal because those are very
inconvenient he's charged with leaking
information about an ongoing
investigation the one into the Clinton
email scandal to The Wall Street Journal
Attorney General session said that
McCabe lacked candor about those leaks
and at times he did so under oath that's
a big no-no now in a response on Friday
night McCabe claims that the media leaks
were done with the permission of the
former FDA FBI director Jim Comey now
that could be a big problem for call me
why well he's
already testified under oath to Congress
that he did not engage in leaking nor
did he authorized any leaks
someone's lying here and we haven't even
talked about Andrew McCabe's conflict of
interest
he should have recused himself from
investigating Hillary Clinton since his
wife Jill when she was running for state
office in Virginia received nearly four
hundred and sixty eight thousand dollars
from Clinton pal Terry McAuliffe's PAC
and by the way for other Clinton
bundlers contributed a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars to mrs. McCabe's
campaign not a bad haul and that doesn't
constitute at least the appearance of a
conflict of interest for her husband who
is investigating mrs. Clinton it is
patently obvious at this point that the
Democrats and their media toady's will
defend and/or ignore any lawlessness so
long as it achieves their political end
which is what to win back power in
Congress and eventually run president
Trump out of office but I was thinking
about this you know this endorsement of
lawlessness looking the other way at
conflicts of interest this isn't an
isolated incident for the left remember
these are the same people who applauded
the compassion and the courage of public
officials who push sanctuary policies in
cities like Chicago Hartford Connecticut
and all across California so the average
working person has to suffer as violent
illegal alien offenders roam free after
being released from jail in places like
Oakland and down in LA and by the way
these are the same people who made all
kind of lame excuses for the rioting and
destruction by mobs and Baltimore
following Freddie Gray's death in ditto
for the nights of looting and fires as
terrible events in Ferguson following
the police shooting of Michael Brown now
recall that juries acquitted the police
officers in each case and by the way the
same type of people who going back to
the Obama era they didn't bat an eye
when Eric Holder declined
execute IRS official Lois Lerner for
discriminating it against conservative
501 C groups and didn't care that Eric
Holder stonewalled Congress regarding
the Fast and Furious scandal which by
the way I forgot until today which led
to a criminal contempt of Congress
resolution against Holder and of course
we all remember there were no
repercussions for Susan Rice remember
when she went out and lied to the
American people about what spurred that
attack on her government compound in
Benghazi Libya in fact the only person
who was actually charged after four
Americans were killed there including
the US ambassador was a man named Ahmed
Abu khattala
and he was found not guilty of 14 of the
18 counts against him unbelievable no
accountability and let us not forget the
Democrats who once prided themselves on
caring about protecting civil liberties
they don't seem at all bothered about
using the vast power of our intelligence
services to spy on members of Donald
Trump's campaign team although the
Democrats and their media surrogates
seem fine with this by any means
necessary approach I do not think most
Americans are check this out is a new
Monmouth poll that finds that over half
of the American public is either very or
somewhat worried that the US government
is monitoring their activities and
invading their privacy in other words
they're noticing the overreach of the
deep state and they don't like it this
matters to voters it should if any of us
had done what McCabe did would probably
already be in jail and he may yet be to
understand the dangers at play here
remember when President Trump vowed to
reform the intelligence services as he
came into office do you recall the
chilling response of Senator Chuck
Schumer at the time so unity you take on
the intelligence community they have six
ways from Sunday at getting back at you
so even for a practical supposedly
hard-nosed businessman
he's being really dumb to do this and
the deep state has tried to get Trump
six ways to Sunday ever since and even
when they are caught as McCabe was
Democrats will defend them because they
all share the same goal at every level
the Democrats have either willingly
enabled or tolerated lawlessness
conflicts of interests and rank bias
within our government because they want
power back and that's why they've
contorted themselves into these pretzels
to protect Hillary and that's why
they're relentlessly pursuing Donald
Trump but I'm telling you this approach
may end up backfiring president Trump's
approval numbers have gone up four
percent to forty three percent in the
last month maybe I'm being too
optimistic maybe but I think Americans
have a strong sense of innate fairness
and if the Democrats idea of public
service is seen to embrace weaponizing
the intelligence spying on American
citizens and yet dismissing obvious
criminal acts when committed by their
own party or illegal immigrants well
they may themselves need a November
miracle to pull off the kind of wave
election that they've been banking on
we'll see and that's the angle